treatment options for cancer includes
surgery radiation therapy chemotherapy
and hormone therapy
there are several surgical options
depending on the severity of the cancer
a lumpectomy removes the tumor and a
small amount of neighboring tissue
mastectomies involve removing the entire
breast and it's tissues sentinel lymph
node removal is typically performed in
addition to lumpectomies and
mastectomies here your surgeon will
remove the lymph node closest to the
tumor and check it for the presence of
cancer cells if this node is clean it
may not be necessary to remove more
lymph nodes
a prophylactic mastectomy is a
preventative surgery for high-risk women
that removes the entire breast to lower
the risk of breast cancer
radiation therapy uses high-energy
x-rays or other types of radiation to
kill the cancer cells or to keep them
from growing
internal radiation therapy can be used
to treat the cancer from the inside of
the body with needles wires or catheters
chemotherapy is a treatment that uses
drugs to stop the growth of cancer cells
by either killing them or inhibiting
their cell division once the drugs enter
the bloodstream they can travel and
reach cancer cells throughout the body
some types of breast cancers need
hormones in order to grow and spread
hormone therapy works by blocking the
cancer cells from receiving the natural
hormones that they need tests can show
if your breast tumour has these
receptors and if it is a good treatment
option